i will say i have sat down personally
with mark zuckerberg i talk about this
in the book
he came to see me in back in september
of 2019 i believe it was
i found that meeting much more
interesting
because that was a face-to-face meeting
which he was really trying to change my
view about facebook
i mean i think that's why he came to see
me this was it in washington in my
senate office and he came to see me and
he really tried to convince me
that facebook should be kind of a
national champion that we
needed facebook to be big and powerful
in order to take on
communist china and he really went on
and on about this uh for quite some time
when i turned the subject to the
question of
monopoly uh he got much less interested
in the conversation
you know said well well you know i mean
we're not a monopoly i said okay
well if you're not if you're not afraid
of competition why don't you sell off
instagram and whatsapp i mean you you
bought them so they wouldn't compete
with you
you didn't you didn't start them you
bought them why don't you sell you want
to spend them off and oh
you know that made him very angry he was
very offended by that
he thought that that was a ridiculous
suggestion and i said well that's
because you're committed to your
monopoly i mean you don't want
competition
you want to be able to control uh the
whole show and that's really the problem
with these companies
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the junior senator from the great state
of missouri
and the author of the new book the
tyranny of big tech
senator josh hawley welcome to the
reuben report thanks for having me
senator what are the chances that this
video is not going to be
algorithmically depressed by youtube do
we have any chance that anyone's going
to see this thing
i i don't know uh given my history with
big tech
maybe not but we'll keep our fingers
crossed i've got a similar history
with big tech so i want to start by i
just literally in the last five minutes
as we sat down with you i saw
two headlines that i thought okay these
are these are perfect to tee up for the
senator so breitbart is just reporting
in the last couple minutes
that i'll read you the exact uh tweet
twitter is reportedly developing a
feature to make users
reconsider sending messages that its
system detects
as quote mean
i suspect very good i suspect that will
include a lot of your stuff
well i suspect what will happen is well
first of all if they actually enforce
that wouldn't that shut down all of
twitter
i thought that's it for twitter twitter
seems to subsist on
but uh of course i in practice i'm sure
that will mean that uh conservatives and
libertarians that their tweets
are all silenced and uh the left can can
go on with the hate mongering as long as
they like that's usually how it works
yeah that that pretty much is it and
then this other one which it
seems obvious and i actually warned that
this was going to be coming
uh twitter is now this is from becker
news
twitter is now suspending users who
share donald trump's statements
so as you know trump launched
ineffective blog it wasn't sort of
people were saying he was going to come
out with this big platform apparently
that's not it
but he launched this thing with just
buttons that could send stuff to twitter
and facebook now they're actually
deleting accounts
that just link to his stuff
yeah that's just it's unbelievable and
their
their determination to completely
silence and erase and cancel
the former president of the united
states it's just it's just shocking and
the fact that they
have the power the monopoly power to do
this
and to get by with it and that there's
nowhere else the former president can go
i mean think about this former president
united states had what
78 and 80 million followers or something
on twitter and
many more on the other platforms and
there's no alternative
for him to go he's got to try and create
his own thing i mean
that tells you something about the
monopoly power of these companies okay
so let's start right at the heart of it
because you are a constitutional
conservative
and at least as far as i know we're
still governed by the constitution
although
i'm not quite sure these days but i know
that a lot of people
every time you say okay we've got to do
something about big tech they say well
what do you mean they're private
companies and
we should just leave them alone what is
your argument against that
well listen a monopoly is a threat to
the free market and also a threat to
liberty i mean this is the problem for
those of us who believe in free market
capitalism
is that monopoly stifles competition
minifi monopoly raises barriers to entry
raises uh barriers to new entrants into
the market slows down
innovation and of course gives the
holders of the monopoly
incredible power in politics and we're
seeing that now
with these big tech companies so i would
just say to those who consider
themselves
defenders of the free market to those
who consider themselves defenders of
capitalism that it is incumbent upon us
to dismantle monopolies so that the
market can function
we could have more competition consumers
could have more choice
bottom line politically is our front our
framers understood
monopoly and liberty do not go together
and we've got to recover
that understanding do you think in some
sense though the ship has just kind of
sailed here you know i covered all the
hearings obviously you you were very
involved in all of those
and when trump was in power there was
this idea that oh maybe something's
going to happen
but at this point biden's in charge and
the democrats are in charge and it's
like well
why would they do anything on this stuff
because it's helping them
yeah there's no doubt i think the
democrats have really fallen in love
with the monopoly power of these
companies and if you listen to those
hearings
and uh cover them as you did you would
you hear over and over is the democrats
saying the companies ought to censor
more yeah
they have to use their power more
aggressively i mean they're no longer
worried about the concentration of power
they're basically cheering the companies
on and then threatening
to regulate them if the companies don't
get more sensorious which is sort of
hard to imagine
but i do think that the democrats have
really given up
on the monopoly question because they've
come to love it but that doesn't mean
that the conservatives have to i mean we
have to now more than ever
get back to their founders understanding
that monopoly and liberty are not
compatible and what we need is more
competition
what we need is to return power and
control to the american people
that includes control over your own
speech control over your own personal
information your personal data
and i think we've got to be bold in
pushing forward reforms and legislative
proposals that will do that
why do you think trump didn't move on
this you know there was this threat of
doing something about section 230 of the
communications act that we've covered a
million times before
but nothing happened what do you think
was the hold up there
i think that really the the white house
didn't get focused on it and uh
the president i think did not begin to
really push it until until it was in an
election season and it was very hard
then at that point
to galvanize congress into action but
also uh the real sticking point was
never the white house it was always
congress and a lot of listen when i came
to
the senate just two years ago and i
began proposing
to reform overhaul section 230 to break
up these monopolies
i couldn't find very many takers on my
side of the aisle i mean there were very
very few republicans who wanted to be
associated with that are involved with
that
and so i think you just didn't have a
lot of enthusiasm and that's because
republican elected officials were a lot
of the times out of step with their own
voters their own voters are saying
wow these companies have too much power
they are radical left they are censoring
speech they are
shutting down uh our speech in the
democratic process interfering with it
but you said republicans who weren't
willing to move on i think that that is
changing but as you say the last two
four years were really a missed
opportunity
for republicans in that respect and now
we've got to make up for lost time and
we can do that by being bold
with our thinking bold in our proposals
and
go to the american people with an agenda
to trust bust
here in the 21st century but do you fear
that now that the democrats are in
charge that
if they were to do anything about all of
this that it would actually just be
worse because you made the point
they were basically saying hey if you
guys don't regulate speech we're going
to punish you i mean that's basically
what aoc said
to zuckerberg and he pretty much was
like well i can't i can't do that i'm
not god
but now that they have the power like
it's hard for me to envision basically
them using that power
to expand freedom yes i i agree with you
i think this is one of the reasons why
i'm very very skeptical of increasing
government regulation over the companies
especially the way the democrats want to
you know democrats
want to further regulate the speech
content
uh that's on uh that's on the web that's
on these platforms i mean that's what
they really want to do and they want to
tell the companies
that you need to define this as
offensive and you need to find that
as threatening and you need to take down
this that i think is exactly the wrong
way to go we don't need less speech we
need
more speech we don't need more political
control we need
less political control and more freedom
on the internet and everywhere else so i
think that the way to go
is not to increase the government
involvement but to break the companies
up i mean let's get the free market
involved again let's get some
competitors in that space
another thing i would say is let's give
people the right to sue these companies
these monopolies
if they get de-platformed and they're
treated in bad faith
you know it used to be i mean it still
is true in every other
walk of life of their every other
industry that if a company violates its
contract with you
you can sue them well with big tech you
can't assume if they violate their terms
of agreement
because the federal government protects
them immunizes them that's section 230.
i think we ought to withdraw that and
allow people to sue
if the if they're treated in bad faith
by these companies if these companies
violate their terms of service i think
that could be a game changer
can you talk about what actually
breaking them up would look like because
i've seen a lot of my more libertarian
friends basically say that is the answer
like they've just sort of hit the end
they got to the end of the road and it's
like all right we don't really like to
do this stuff
but i think they're kind of with you
it's like we have no choice what does
that actually mean so okay we're going
to break up twitter like what does that
really look like
well here's where i would start i would
start by making these companies spin off
all of the various industries that
they've tried to consolidate under their
control
so for example amazon amazon has the
dominant e-commerce platform in the
world we're all familiar with that it
also though has a major major share if
not a controlling share in the cloud
that's aws
it also has its own retail line of
products that it sells on its own
platform using information from
competitors
they shouldn't be able to do all of
these things at once i mean this is
really what what used to be called a
conglomerate merger where you have this
massive conglomeration of industries
under one set of hand one set of hands
under one control
i think we ought to make them spin those
companies off by just saying in law that
they can't combine
these different industries into one
giant tech company almost all these tech
companies do it
i mean google does the same thing right
google has a
search of course the dominant search
platform in the world
but google also owns the advertising the
digital advertising sphere
at a monopoly level such that if you
want to advertise anything in the
internet you've got to go through google
we should make them spin off those
businesses sell them off facebook
whatsapp instagram
they should have to sell those off so
that when i think about breaking up big
tech that's where i would start
let's let's reverse this conglomerate
mergers that big tech
has done and performed by gobbling up
all of these other companies
and let's begin to reintroduce some
competition so you don't think we can
send a couple government bureaucrats
into the google offices to look at the
algorithm and fix that thing
is that what you're saying you know i
think that
and that's the kind of uh expertise i
don't trust the federal government to do
much of anything i certainly don't trust
them
uh to try and fine-tune these companies
and i would say that what what that
really amounts to
to be to get serious about it that
really amounts to a form of corporatism
that's when the government says to big
business you know what
why don't we partner up and we'll work
hand in glove and we'll work together
that's what the democrats want i think
the democrats have become corporatists
they want to see this alliance between
big business and big government
they're pursuing and building that
alliance i think as conservatives we
should say no no we reject that whole
premise we don't want
big business or big government we don't
want them working together we want
competition
we want there to be liberty and we're
going to pursue policies that will get
that
can you talk a little bit about what
it's like to be in those meetings like
when you're sitting there and you're
looking at
jack from twitter who looks like he just
got off a three-week ayahuasca trip and
you got
zuckerberg who looks like he was just
pulled off like a synthetic human
you know like whatever like
what what do you make of these guys like
really like what what is that experience
like also knowing that the entire world
is watching everything they say watching
everything you say it's all going to be
cut and edited in crazy ways and
everything else
i've actually found that their
appearances before the committees and
for my case it's the judiciary committee
that they've appeared before a number of
times tend to be very uh shall we say
unenlightening
they don't and you know this yeah
covered it yeah commented on it analyze
it
you know they say nothing over and over
and over again and they try to say
nothing in new and more interesting ways
and uh you know i i personally think
that those those hearings have a value
in putting questions to them
and exposing the fact that they
prevaricate and obstucate and sometimes
just outright lie
you know that's the value but in terms
of actually extracting information
they really they don't give you anything
there's really little value there i will
say
i have sat down personally with mark
zuckerberg i talk about this in the book
he came to see me in back in september
of 2019
i believe it was i found that meeting
much more
interesting because that was a
face-to-face meeting which he was really
trying to change my view about facebook
i think that's why he came to see me
this was it
in washington in my senate office and he
came to see me and he really tried to
convince me
that facebook should be kind of a
national champion that we
needed facebook to be big and powerful
in order to take on
communist china and he really went on
and on about this uh for quite some time
when i turned the subject to the
question of
monopoly uh he got much less interested
in the conversation
you know well well you know i mean we're
not a monopoly yeah we don't i said okay
well if you're not if you're not afraid
of competition why don't you sell
off instagram and whatsapp i mean you
you bought them so that they wouldn't
compete with you
you didn't you didn't start them you
bought them why don't you sell you want
to spend them off and oh
you know that made him very angry he was
very offended by that he thought that
that was a ridiculous suggestion
and i said well that's because you're
committed to your monopoly i mean you
don't want competition
uh you want to be able to control uh the
whole show and that's really the problem
with these companies
do you have some sympathy for these guys
when they're testifying like zuckerberg
there you know in that moment when he
kind of said you know we just can't do
all of this stuff that's what he said to
aoc
i actually kind of sympathize with the
guy i know it's hard to sympathize
with these people but at some level you
know they start these tech companies i
don't think they're all evil
necessarily i think they get lost in
their own thing and it's almost an
unwinnable position in a bizarre sense
um but do you have any sympathy for him
you know i don't tend to be very
sympathetic when i'm getting lied to
and i do think that they have
deliberately misled
uh congress uh many times and would do
it and will do it if you let them get by
with it i will say that though sometimes
depending on who's questioning them
uh you do actually feel a little bit
sympathy and some of the questions that
they have to answer are really
ludicrous and ridiculous but on the
whole my view is these guys are
billionaires
uh they're not stupid people as you
point out these are very capable people
uh they didn't get to where they are by
being dumb i mean they're very
they're very smart they're very
accomplished and they could certainly
hold their own so i tend not to feel too
sorry for them i wish they'd be more
forthcoming
i wish they'd be a little bit more
honest but at the end of the day
we can't look to anyone's ceo's personal
characteristics and personal character
traits and
hope for the best what we've got to do
is make decisions about the structure of
our economy and when you have monopolies
who are actively suppressing competition
and actively trying to control speech
that's a problem and it doesn't really
matter who's in charge of the company
what matters is what they're doing as a
company and their power
and we've got to do something about that
yeah do you sense that also some of this
is that they can use a lot of linguistic
tricks to get out of all of the legal
stuff so they'll use phrases like
deboosting or shadow banning or
unbiasing all of these things that they
mean something but they mean different
things to different people so
i've had jack from twitter tweet
directly at me and respond to me say
we don't shadowband well it's like we
all know that you shadow man but he may
in his
mind just have a different definition of
what shadow band is so they they make up
words so that they're never really on
the hook for anything
that's right you know this has happened
repeatedly it was interesting in the
hearing the last hearing
uh where these folks came before the
judiciary committee was i think in
november
of 2020 so just a few months ago and
shortly before
that hearing i had had a a former
employee of facebook a whistleblower
come to my office
and say that he had information he
wanted to share about facebook's
censorship practices and i tell some of
this story
in the book and one of the things he
revealed to me and revealed to my staff
was the existence of an internal
facebook platform called cintra
which allows the company it's like a
souped-up surveillance platform and it
allows the company to track
their users across multiple different
platforms
including across different user names
and aliases
and to track their posts to track their
internet activity to track what they're
doing in different countries their
geolocation i mean
it's extraordinary and he shared with
the screenshots of this platform
in use with particular individuals it
was amazing so i get to the hearing
and i asked zuckerberg about this he was
clearly
very surprised to be asked but he
initially tried to deny it by
very carefully choosing his words and
saying i'm not familiar
with any such tool by that name
plausible deniability right
yeah wait a minute i said so are you
telling me that it doesn't exist or
you're telling me that you you call it
something else i mean what is it you're
trying to say eventually by the way
facebook admitted
they do have that tool and it is called
citra so he was wrong on all accounts
but
he engaged in this back and forth with
me where he was desperately trying to
thread this needle to not outright deny
it but to suggest i was wrong
and that's what they do all the time
does anyone go to jail after any of
these things i mean i know not not
zuckerberg or
or jack dorsey from twitter but like
when they do that
sort of pretty much lie thing does
anyone ever get punished for lying to
congress anymore
is that a thing not really no not really
you know i can remember a time that a
google executive
had testified also before the judiciary
committee and i was asking him about the
tracking
that google performs on its android
phones and i i said that uh
you know even if you turn off the
location services on your phone
uh it it still tracks you right and he
initially outright said to me no
that's not accurate i said really and so
we started walking through it and i said
i
i thought that even with location
services off
the wi-fi function on your phone still
scanned for other wi-fi in the area
still made a note of it
still stored that information and still
communicated it back to google and then
he said oh well yeah that's true
i said well so it's still tracking you
at which point i said well
i would use the word tracking i mean so
there you go i mean where it's this
constant constant game to get them to be
honest with you sometimes about the most
basic stuff i mean i
often think that these these tech folks
when you put them on the stand if you if
you
put them under oath if you ask them if
the sun was shining outside they would
prevaricate
well you know define sun yeah so uh
that's how these hearings go
do you think some of your involvement of
this is not only because i know you
actually care about the constitution and
freedom and i want to talk about
lockdowns and a lot more obviously
but also because you're younger than the
average senator and partly what we have
going on
here is a 78 year old president
and i got i'm here in california i got
like 106 year old senator and feinstein
like we have these
old and i'm not even that's i don't mean
that to be aegis pelosi we have these oh
and even trump was 74 he would be 75
right now
if he was president that that baby
boomer generation
is just hanging on to power too long and
now there's these new industries
and they don't know how to react to
these things i do think there is a
generational component
to this i think there's no doubt about
it and and i can tell you just from
my experience in in questioning on the
judiciary committee
there were multiple times where i would
be asking a line of questioning that
this is this is really not earth
shattering stuff i mean this is
even about location services we're just
talking about a lot of people know that
but i was asking some of these questions
and i had older colleagues
who just aren't familiar with these
technologies right they just don't i
mean they probably do have an iphone or
an android but they don't they don't
really use it that much they use to make
calls that's it you know their staff
does a lot of the other stuff
and i i had them come up to me
afterwards
and say i've never heard that before is
that true
i don't i i wasn't aware that any of
this was going on and that's
been a pretty common response i think
that's just generational i think that
you know they're not as familiar with
this technology and that's one of the
reasons why in these hearings
you've really seen especially especially
a couple of years ago you could really
see the tech executives
uh tie up members of congress and not
because
you know the initial question might be
pretty darn good from a senator
congressman but then the response
you know they just wouldn't know how to
respond and and the tech ceo or
executive would give a prevaricating
response and
and then there was no follow-up there
was no way to untangle
that web that they had just spun so i'm
glad that as more people get focused on
this
and spend more time getting prepped for
this i think congress is getting better
at doing oversight but to go back to
earlier point
we can talk all we want about oversight
hearings lots of talk
we have to do something we can talk all
we want but the time has come to do
something about this and and the book is
that's partly what this book is about
yeah okay so let's
so we're sort of dancing around all the
topics in the book but let's talk about
the book so it's called the tyranny of
big tech and
ironically the book almost didn't get
published can you
explain what happened there yeah that's
right
the book was initially a commissioned by
simon schuster
one of the two biggest publishers i
believe i'm right saying in the country
and simon schuster actually has been
purchased by the biggest publisher of
the company so
the country so there you have further
industry consolidation uh just like
everywhere else but simon schuster
uh signed a contract for the book uh
before it was written you know sort of
commissioned me in that sense to write
the book i wrote it
uh they saw it were happy with it and
then in january they said oh
oh actually you know what we're not
gonna publish it we don't think you
should be able to
we don't think you should be able to
speak and uh they said that you know i i
actually they said to me nothing they
they never reached out to me personally
i read this in a press release
that's incredible so they never reached
anyone on your team to say
i mean just even legally you'd think
they'd have to reach out to your lawyer
to say hey we're severing the contract
or something i think what they did is
is that they they sent i think they made
a phone call an informal phone call to
the the folks who wrote to my agent and
said we're gonna we're gonna cancel this
but they didn't send they didn't reach
out to me they didn't send a letter they
didn't they then they did a press
release and he said well
why what are you going to say it's like
well we'll be putting out a statement
and so it's like well i guess we'll read
it
i guess we'll read the statement which
is what i did you know i read their
statement which
uh directly i can't remember the exact
words now but basically said that you
know well holly helped incite a riot
on capitol hill and you get the
impression from that that you know i was
there at a criminal riot
a rioter on the hill totally false 100
false they knew it was false and the
whole reason they did it is because they
went along with the woke left mob
that wanted to cancel and still does
wants to cancel conservatives
wants to cancel trump supporters wants
to cancel anybody
who will not bow down to their woke
mentality and their woke agenda and i
wouldn't then and i won't now
and i'm delighted that the book founded
an independent publisher who had the
guts
to publish it who believes in you know
free speech a pretty basic american
value and now people can
read for themselves yeah well let's give
ragnary a little shout out here because
they're the ones that picked up the book
and
and they've picked up a couple other
controversial books
uh the parasitic mind by my friend gad
sad another one really going after the
woke
and and they picked him up as well um
what is it that you want people to
mainly take away from this i mean is it
is it just to so that they understand
the issues
better like what do you want the average
person to do after they read this book
well i want them to to say that first of
all these there's no reason we have to
accept the power of these tech
monopolies
we don't just have to accept it i think
that's often what we're told you know
well
this is just how it is and yeah if you
use
these platforms as overwhelming
majorities of americans do you're just
gonna have to get used to having your
data taken from you
and you're just gonna have to get used
to being spied on all over the web and
you're just going to get used to your
children being tracked
and that's just our economy that's how
it is it's not how it has to be it's not
at all we can do something about that
these tech companies got big and
powerful with the help of government
now it's time to cut them down to size
and restore the free market so i think
that's the message
i want people to feel a sense of
empowerment that things can be different
and they will be different if we demand
it and also we've got some control in
our own lives you know we need to we
need to
address this situation politically and
legally we need to cut these companies
down to size
but also personally you know we can do
things that will take back control we
can spend less time on the platforms we
can take steps that will limit their
ability to spy on us
we can try to get them out of our
children's lives and i share about some
of that in the book
yeah i don't know if you know this but i
do uh every august off the grid no
phone no computer no news no nothing
and it's i honestly think it's one of
the things that has helped keep me sane
over the last couple years because
that news cycle and that endless scroll
you know everyone calls it doom
scrolling
where it's just more and more and more
and more it's actually
it's making people crazy it is it is
making people crazy and i discuss some
of the data in the book you know what
we're seeing especially with young
people
we're seeing startling correlation
between increased
device and especially social media use
and
depression isolation anxiety and suicide
it's really the statistics are really
really alarming and again it's pretty
it's this is true the depression piece
of it's true for people of all ages but
it's
really pronounced among young people and
especially young females young women
the social media use and then the
correlation between that and depression
and even suicide is really stark and
this is something that we need
to get out in the open and that the tech
companies need to be responsible for you
know they want to act as if oh my gosh
they're the model citizens
and their their products are all about
making our lives easier and better
well actually their products are about
addiction and their model is to addict
us and that has
major major negative consequences and so
we
we need to do something about that and
that starts with us personally and
your example is a great one i should see
if i could follow that great example
but where we say listen i'm going to
take back some control of my own life
and
i'm not going to live my life on these
platforms day in and day out
yeah which everyone is doing constantly
trust me i don't know if as a senator
you can take a month off
but it is the best thing that you can
possibly do i mean
i can actually feel my brain resetting
during it it really
it's something what do you think about
uh that some of the states are taking
some of this into their hands i mean ron
desantis who i
pretty much think is is the best
governor we've got in this country at
this point
you know he's basically saying if you
deplatform
a political candidate from florida we're
going to find you i think i think it was
a hundred grand a day or 200 grand a day
something like that
do you think that that it can work sort
of at the state level or do we need does
it have to be kind of federal
well i think ultimately we will have to
do something at the federal level i mean
particularly to break up the monopolies
but
the states absolutely should do
everything they can and i love
what governor desantis is doing in
florida i think there's a similar
proposal maybe in texas and a few other
places
and as a i used to be the attorney
general of the state of missouri that's
what i did before i was in the united
states senate and in that capacity
i filed an anti-trust investigation the
first of its kind in the country against
google and facebook both
so there is absolutely a role for the
states here a role for governors
state legislators and attorneys general
to go after these companies in every way
possible and especially now when you've
got the democrats
really cozying up to big tech really
falling in love with their monopoly
power and democrats in charge of course
in washington uh we've got to use every
tool at our disposal
to try to hold these companies
accountable and try to give the american
people some control back and i i just i
applaud
these states who are doing it yeah let's
let's shift from big tech a little bit
uh to just some of the the broader stuff
so because you are a constitutional
conservative and it seems to me
that the constitution is under complete
assault right now that the democrats
whether it's packing you know expanding
the courts or getting rid of the
electoral college
or moving on guns or certainly the free
speech stuff as related to big tech and
everywhere else
it seems that the constitution is just
being attacked
and i wonder if there are enough people
at this point because our education
system is so screwy if there are just
enough people
who will stand up and fight for it
because they don't even know what
they're fighting for anymore
you know particularly when it comes to
speech just to start with that piece of
it it has been
remarkable to see even in the last five
years
the collapse of treasuring and valuing
free speech among the sort of leading
institutions in this country think of
our universities
the institutional press the legacy press
these folks who used to be even though
they were leftists
used to be defenders of free speech to
some degree and now we're not at all in
fact
to the contrary if they disagree with
you they want you silenced if they
disagree with you they want you canceled
so this i think is is a is a remarkable
development and a
really really dangerous one because if
we're not free to speak
then we can't deliberate and if we can't
deliberate we can't have self-government
i mean the whole idea of our republic is
is that
the normal people everyday people should
have control
over their lives and control over their
government and we ought to be making the
decisions and we make the decisions
because we talk together and
we're able to converse together and if
we're not able to do that freely you
know if you've got these companies or
the government
interfering and saying nope can't say
that no you can't you can't express that
view nope
i mean my gosh how is our democracy to
go on
so i do think that we are at to your
point as constitutionalists
we're at a moment of great peril and we
need to be bold in standing up for the
constitution because you talk
in this moment of division by the way
there should be nothing that unites us
like the constitution
and i think and the principles it's
based on and i think we've got to be
bold and going out there and fighting
for those
how much of that do you think has to do
with sort of the general collapse of
liberalism that the progressives
have just wiped away any of the old
school liberals because
even though you're a republican and a
conservative i suspect you probably
enjoyed having debates with liberals at
one time and now
i don't know where those liberals are i
used to be one of them my whole book is
defending liberalism except
i'm defending something that seemingly
is gone
yeah i think that's right i do think you
think about the liberal tradition
that this country is part of the
tradition of freedom of speech freedom
of worship
free government uh that is something
that today's so-called liberals
really have abandoned and uh you know
again
it's happened with such speed i mean
even when i was in law school which
wasn't all that long ago a decade or
more ago when i was in college before
that
you could still have robust debate on
campus you could have events where you
had a
conservative you had a liberal you had a
libertarian you had a liberal
and they would go at it people come and
listen they wouldn't try to shout down
the conservative viewpoint but that is
increasingly difficult today
on many many many american campuses and
it's that same sort of campus culture
that woke leftism that is spreading into
every
sector of our society at least into the
into the areas of influence you know
it's the leadership class
in this country a self-appointed
leadership class that is really
imposing this wokism and this cancel
culture on the rest of the country
are you shocked are you shocked how the
democrats just kind of folded because if
you
asked me seven years ago say like was
nancy pelosi truly this radical
i actually don't think so chuck schumer
certainly i don't think was really this
radical joe biden i mean i
don't know what he believes anymore but
i don't think you know he's ushering in
all of this now i mean are you shocked
how quickly they all folded
i'm i'm very surprised at how hard to
the left they have turned
so quickly and i think what it probably
tells you is that for
for decades now their commitment to core
constitutional principles has been
weakening you know we saw it
earlier i think with freedom of worship
uh that has been one where the democrat
that used to be a very bipartisan issue
it used to be that people would say hey
religious liberty
that is a that is a core core
constitutional conviction
and whatever faith you are of or even if
you're a person of no faith at all like
we should all be able to agree protect
religious liberty
the democrats walked away from that now
20 plus years ago
and you've seen them do the same thing
with free speech uh i predict that
freedom of the press they basically have
done the same thing if you're
conservative outlet i mean that's the
100 by new york or post story right i
mean if you're a conservative outlet no
you shouldn't publish
so it has been their move towards a
a form of control-oriented liberalism
uh is really exceptional and uh this
woke-ism
which again is basically like my way or
the highway either you agree with me or
you're a terrible person
and you should be silenced and not able
to participate in public life
yeah do you sense more people are waking
up to this i mean
obviously you're talking about it from a
political position plenty of people like
me talking about it i i
sense there's like some pushback
starting now but you know there's still
a lot of people that are that are
awfully afraid of this thing
well i think that that voters i mean
again working people
everyday working people i think they
hate this woke-ism i think they hate it
i think they hate being told
that you you have to use this particular
set of words you can't use that set of
words and by the way it changes all the
time
and again it's it's it's the
self-appointed leaders of the country
who will tell you what you can and
cannot say i think they
hate that stuff and you know what people
also hate being told all the time that
they're bigoted
that they're backward that they're
racist and that's
basically what the democrat party in the
left says to
at least half this country maybe more is
that since you don't agree with them
well that's because you're a racist if
you believe in the constitution and are
proud of the history of this country
you're a bigot
i mean if you don't agree to go along
with their agenda to transform our
society to cancel women's sports for
instance
uh then there's something deeply wrong
with you and and you are a terrible
person i think people are
sick of that and this is frankly one of
the reasons i think president trump
became president
is because he was willing to call it out
and people said oh thank you
someone who is willing to stand up to
this nonsense and and i don't think
that's changed i think even folks who
would identify
as being more liberal uh they say
i don't agree with this this woke-ism
and this effort to control
speech and ideas as i always say
defending my liberal
beliefs is becoming a conservative
position it's a it's a very
it's a very odd time we live in um let's
shift a little bit to
some of the other things going on here
so we we still i suppose according to
the infallible fouchy we are in inning
six
of the pandemic that's what he told wolf
blitzer a couple days ago
um what what should the average person
feel about the pandemic at this point in
the government response to it
well i mean here's the thing you hear
more and more people in washington
complaining about the fact that uh there
aren't more americans who are getting
vaccinated
and part of my response to this is is
that if there's not gonna make any
difference
to anybody in their daily life if you
get vaccinated or not why would somebody
go get vaccinated
full disclosure i'm vaccinated i
recommend people get vaccinated but it's
their personal decision right it's a
medical decision
people got to make that decision for
themselves and if your message to them
is yeah
go get this vaccine does that mean that
i can wear i could take off my mask nope
does that mean that i can get together
with the extended family nope does that
mean i can go to a full-scale sporting
event nope they're like well
okay well what's the point then i just
think that
you can't have it always and they're
just this fear-mongering i saw this
hilarious article i think it was in the
new york times not long ago
where the times was wondering why is it
that people are so afraid of covet 19
and and have
all of these irrational fears about it
and i thought i don't know why do you
think
maybe it's because of your hysterical
irresponsible coverage
for months and months over a year now
where you are not content
to just report the facts to the american
people and inform them
but you really want to control them and
and i think that's what i hear from
folks at home
is they say we just feel like we're
constantly being controlled that the
government wants to control us they want
to control our behavior
just give us the facts tell us what the
real situation is
and then you know what we're pretty
reasonable people we'll do the
reasonable thing but
that doesn't seem to be what the uh the
the experts in dc want
do you think it's in some ways too late
to fix that that the expert class and
the intellectual elite class
they have so either often been wrong or
misled us or
however you want to characterize it i
don't think people want to listen to
them anymore for example
it's a year and a half past two weeks to
flatten the curve those
those first two weeks everybody
everybody wore masks
everyone's socially distanced everyone
stayed at home we did exactly
everybody we did exactly what they
wanted us to do now we don't even talk
about that phrase anymore because it
would sort of show how ridiculous this
all was
yeah and the goalposts have constantly
moved i know i think to your question
has a leadership class that ruined its
credibility yes
they have i mean this is this is part of
what we see going on in the country
right now is that everyday
normal working people they don't trust
the leadership of this country and
that's not just the political leaders
the elected leaders they don't trust
people
in the in the leadership class the media
the legacy media the press
uh the leaders of the major corporations
they don't trust them
because they think that those people a
live differently than the rest of the
country b
don't understand the rest of the country
and c want to control the rest of the
country and you know what they're pretty
much right
on a b and c i mean that's pretty much
true my view is is that
you hear all the time usually from the
experts about how oh
you know the the typical american and
the typical american worker you know
doesn't work hard enough
isn't well educated enough isn't willing
to take the tough jobs i don't believe
any of that
i think that's exactly wrong the typical
american is the hope of this country the
problem is with the leaders in this
country
the problems with the leadership class
in this country
and they are desperately trying to hold
on to their power while telling
everybody else what they can and cannot
say
and can and cannot do with their lives
and i think people are sick of it
where are you guys in missouri at right
now in terms of lockdowns and
regulations and all that stuff
well we never had actually a statewide
mass command day we have a republican
governor and and he said listen
i'm going to give the the local states
and and uh
sorry the local cities and counties the
ability to make their own decisions on
on masking and
and so forth and i thought that was the
right decision so we never had a mass
mandate in the state of missouri
and now those counties that did have a
mass mandate most of those are now gone
or at least
they're significantly relaxed and our
numbers continue now to be very very low
and the vaccine deployment is going
forward more people are getting it so i
you know i thought that my state
actually took a very sensible approach
to this which was
give people the facts you know put it
out there what what's the
what's the infection rate right now
what's the total number of cases how
many people have recovered and get break
it down
county by county let people see all of
that
let them make their own decisions and
then let local municipalities make their
own decisions i thought that was a
pretty a pretty good move
is part of the problem though that half
the country just doesn't see that i mean
if you're watching msnbc you are not
going to see that the numbers
are incredibly low in florida you're not
going to see their low in missouri
you're not going to see their low in
tennessee
and you're not going to see their low in
texas um so
people don't see it and then they go oh
well it can't be true if you can't you
can't
see it you can't know it's there yeah i
do think that's a problem and this is
where the irresponsibility of much of
the legacy media the lefty media really
i think comes into play
the alternative universe that they have
constructed
particularly these left-wing outlets
that they have constructed is
really irresponsible it's really really
irresponsible and again what it does is
that it creates such a mood of hysteria
then the people they can't get the facts
they have trouble making
a rational choice and then ultimately
they feel betrayed but it turns out that
so much
of the hype is wrong with so much of its
disinformation then they say okay well
i'm never going to trust any of these
people ever again
some cases i mean just their outright
falsehoods that they told about
this pandemic i just remember you know
on that point back in the early spring
last year where we were
lectured and heckled and told do not
wear a mask you know you're un-american
if you're wearing a mask why are you
wearing a mask you know people naturally
i remember this in march i think of last
year people were like oh well
maybe i'll get a mask and wear that and
you know the hectoring no no no you
mustn't you mustn't wear a mess
and then what basically just three or
four weeks later we were told you must
wear a mask you absolutely must it's
essential you do i mean
i think people again are just they are
tired of that
and uh it's taken its toll in the
credibility of the people
uh who are always reporting it always
forcing it down our throats and never
admitting in the past when they were
wrong
right and then of course you know when
trump went for a china ban
uh that was racist now biden has an
india ban
is that racist i'm not sure senator is
that racist yeah well i haven't heard a
word about it i mean i get you know
apparently it's not and msnbc says it's
not it must not be
uh but you know i i was the i was one of
the senators who was urging i called for
travel restrictions
very early on uh to to and from china
uh and i in fact i may have been one of
the first center to do so certainly one
of the first and i urged the president
to
pursue that ban and to enact those
travel restrictions it was absolutely
the right call at the time but oh yeah i
mean all the democrats were this is
this is ridiculous it's fear-mongering
you remember that oh it's fear-mongering
and then these same people a month later
trump hasn't done enough he
never took this seriously i mean it's
just you know if it's not one thing it's
another and again this is why
they bear a lot of responsibility i
think for the inaccuracies and for the
outright
uh falsehoods in some cases that they
perpetrated yeah
so since you do care about that old
piece of paper that
set up this country i thought maybe you
could explain
i talk about it a lot on the show but i
i think you'll be able to
uh explain it pretty clearly the
difference the sort of guarantee of the
constitution of equality
versus what the left is now pushing on
us which is equity
well listen i mean the equality
guarantee is that as citizens
we have the same rights to stand before
the law
and to participate in our democracy as
any other citizen does
and this is the country is is founded on
on this premise
in many ways and this is sort of our
core bedrock guarantee that you know you
don't have to be
born to a certain family or born in a
certain zip code or have a certain
amount of wealth in order to matter in
this country
and we think that every person matters i
look back to you know thomas jefferson
has this great
phrase where he says that cultivators of
the earth you know farmers
are the most valuable of citizens now i
come from a farming family so
i heard that a lot growing up and i i
tend to i tend to agree with it
but it was revolutionary statement at
jefferson's time because you know if you
look back in human history
people who worked with their hands were
usually dismissed you know i was like oh
i mean that's manual labor that's for
people who can't get educated
who aren't smart and the idea that
manual laborers would have a role would
be a
citizen and would have a role in
democrat i mean absolutely not yeah the
romans for instance the greeks
they would never have allowed that our
country is premised
on the idea that folks who who work for
a living are
valuable and that everybody should stand
as an equal before the law and it's the
law that should rule
the law made by the people and not not
any particular person or group of people
so that is
that is a long answer i guess to what i
think our constitution our core
constitutional commitment is
what the left wants though now is
identity politics i mean what they want
to say
is is that they want to define uh this
group that group they want to put
americans they want to divvy us up by
race they want to divvy us up by
identities that they will construct that
the left will construct they'll tell us
which identities are legitimate and
which not
and they want to divvy us up along those
lines and they want to pit one group
against another
and that's what they are doing that's
what a lot of this woke agenda is that's
what a lot of this critical race theory
agenda really and movement really
amounts to and
that i i would submit to you is severely
damaging
to the kind of equality that the
constitution actually guarantees
have you seen this bill i think it's
just circulating in the last little bit
this
it has something to do with the coveted
relief bill where they they are actually
going to help
farmers of color before they help white
farmers
have you heard about this yeah yeah in
fact that's law i mean that's
that's oh it actually is the law now i
mean it is the law of the land
yes it is the law of the land what do we
do what do we do
systemic racism is here yeah yeah oh
it's i mean
it's it's here and and in force
absolutely it was in the last coven
relief bill and
i tell you this stuff is it's just
really extraordinary uh you know i took
a lot of heat
for being the only republican in the
senate to vote no on what was called
the the asian american hate crime bill
was senator hirono's bill
this is a few weeks ago the reason i
voted no was because it didn't have
anything to do with with hate crimes
those are already illegal
it gave the department of justice the
power to define of
hate incidents which is offensive speech
so it gives the government the power to
decide well this speech is offensive
that speech is offensive and then it it
gives doj the power to help states and
local governments track it and monitor
it and create a database i was like this
is crazy
i mean this is this is a first major
first amendment problems here
so i'm against hate crimes but i'm not
i'm not for the government
uh censoring and defining and tracking
speech for heaven's sake
so this kind of thing is becoming more
and more common and we need
conservatives and constitutionalists to
call it out to stand up and
have the courage of their convictions do
you think the legal system is the only
thing that fixes that like to me
that being a part of the package as
you're saying it is law now i mean there
there
i actually i just heard just this
morning that there is a farmer
who is now going to sue so i guess i and
i must have in fact known that it had
been passed
but there is a white farmer who's going
to sue because he is not by the color of
his skin
going to get the same relief as another
farmer because of the color
of their skin is the only recourse
really that it has to get to the courts
and then basically we have to pray
that the courts do the right thing i
think it is now for that package once it
becomes law
you know i mean then then the only
recourse you have left
is to try to go to the courts and to try
to rely on the constitution and defend
your rights and
you know look i'm i'm a constitutional
lawyer by trade i was a prosecutor in
the state of missouri
as attorney general and so i i'm
certainly not averse to going to the
courts
but i will say this that it would be
much much better
if we actually stopped these kind of
destructive policies from becoming law
in the first place
if we actually stopped the woke agenda
from getting enacted into law
and we need more folks who are willing
to stand up and do that and i think
right now there's a real sentiment of
well we just have to kind of go along in
washington dc
we don't have to go along it doesn't
have to be like this we can present a
credible
alternative and we can make the case for
the core
principles of our constitution and we
need to do you think part of this is
just that a certain set of republicans
kind of want to be liked
they just you know the sort of mitt
romney liz cheney
that's that battle that's happening now
where it's sort of the media loves
these people that only years ago they
were telling everyone that mitt romney's
racist because he was running against
barack obama
but now he's a hero because he's sort of
against
say trump or you or ted cruz something
like that the guys who are actually
doing something but they're i keep
calling them the pet republicans because
they can get people on msnbc to say nice
things about them
i do think that the media is really
invested the legacy media establishment
media the leftists are really invested
in this idea of a republican civil war
so they really want to create conflict
and play it up
between uh establishment to republicans
and uh
and and conservatives or populist
republicans i can just tell you
from being homo in the state of missouri
and talking to actual people you know i
mean actual voters
they have no interest in a republican
civil war there is no such thing they
made up their mind they're like what's
the conflict
i mean they don't want to go back to
open borders and to
ruinous trade policies and to liberal
globalism they don't want to go back to
that at all so they're like
what what's the conflict you're talking
about no no no no they want to go
forward they want to know what we're
going to do
to stop this radical left woke agenda
that president biden is trying to force
down our throats is trying to ramrod
through the senate i mean
and then they want to know going forward
what we're going to do to actually
defend our constitution
to actually get jobs back in this
country manufacturing back in this
country
and and give working people a voice
again that's what they want to know
about and
you know i think that this media
narrative that you're pointing to and
talking about
it's just it's it's false and it's meant
to distract from where people
really are so what should the messaging
be i mean i guess that's sort of what
you're saying
what should the messaging be for
republicans going forward because i feel
like it's still
you know nobody really knows who's in
charge is this trump's party still
is it going some other way like what
what do you think that messaging looks
like
well i think we ought to listen to our
voters i think what our voters want is
they want us to be a pro worker family a
pro worker a party rather that we are
four working
americans that we are going to work to
get good jobs
that pay good wages for folks right
where they are that you shouldn't have
to move to a foreign country
in order to get a good job that you
shouldn't have to move halfway around
the country to get a good job we need to
be
the party of working people we need to
be the party of families you know we
need to be out there fighting for
families to be able
to afford to start a family and to raise
a family and by the way
to be able to make their own decisions
about their family and i talk about this
in the book
big tech shouldn't raise our kids we
should raise our kids and american
families want to have the authority and
the power to raise their kids and tell
big tech get out of my life
i want to raise my own children so i
think as a party who are we we're the
party of working america
we're the party of working families in
this country
and we need to be advancing an agenda
that's pro-worker and pro-family i think
that is our future
as a party if it's not i mean if if
republicans are not willing
to be to be the party of working people
and to be the party of working families
then we're not going to have a future as
a party i mean it's just that simple
that that is who our voters are and if
we're not going to be responsive to them
if we're going to be the party of wall
street or if we're going to be the party
of the globalist we're not going to have
a party
where does trump fit into that equation
oh i think that's up to him you know i
mean i think that i don't know what he
wants to do or will do in 2024 or beyond
but i think that is entirely up to him
he's
i can tell you in missouri he still
enjoys among republicans
a very very strong support because i
think people look at his
at his policies that we've just been
talking about they look at that they say
yeah
i agree with the direction that he was
taking this country i agree
with the policy uh proposals and vision
he was putting forward so
i think i think it's entirely up to him
as to what happens next for him i have
no insight into into what decision
uh decisions plural he will make
but uh i think the ball's in his court
on that so i got one more for you which
is a question i often get
from my audience which is
are you hopeful do you do you actually
because we've talked about some serious
stuff here i mean the
the big tech threat the ever-expanding
government threat the woke-ism threat
rampaging the institutions i mean this
is
this is serious stuff but you know
you're in the middle of the fight are
you hopeful
i am hopeful i am hopeful and i'll tell
you why it's because i i
firmly firmly believe that if you go
to the heart of this country if you go
to the working people of this country if
you go to the working families of this
country you'll find strength there
our people are strong our families are
strong our working folks are strong
they're strong in spirit
they're strong in their convictions
about our constitution and about our
country
they're not the problem the problem is
the leadership class that's the problem
you know if the situation were reversed
i i'd be really worried
but i think that the great majority of
this country the great middle of this
country and
i don't mean just middle geographically
i mean the middle of our society
is is strong that's where the strength
is that's what we've got to do
that's why what we have to do are
advanced policies
that give more opportunity that bring
more strength to the middle of our
country and give them a greater voice
because they're the ones who are going
to be able to lead this country forward
and what we've got to do is the the
leadership class which has become
increasingly out of touch increasingly
corrupt
we've got to replace them and we've got
to give more power to the middle
well the book actually got published it
is called the tyranny of big tech
senator josh hawley i appreciate you
doing the show thanks so much for having
me
thanks if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell